hi in this video I'm going to talk about
confocal microscopy so unless other
microscopy confocal microscopy works on
the principle of fluorescence so in
confocal microscopy we must have a laser
laser module a laser module from this
laser module laser would be focused on
two of the spots and a laser would go to
the particular specimen and illuminate
the specimen or in a tight spot and
that's the property of laser so here we
have a dichroic mirror then we have a
lens and say here we have our objective
lens now let us eliminate the specimen
which is present here our specimen is
present here in the slide say for
instance is a sail and now let's
eliminate it with a blue light so laser
would go to this dichroic mirror it
would be reflected down through the
objective lens it would be tightly
focused on to a diffracted diffraction
limited spot into the specimen so that's
the property of laser and due to its
coherence high degree of spatial
coherence laser could be tightly focused
onto a particular spot onto our specimen
and this is called a waste a waste is
produced and this is our excited light
so as per our basic diagram of the
fluorescence if it is our s 0 state and
it's or s 1 excited state when we hit
the specimen with the light now with a
blue light it would get up in the s-1
state so this is the excitation beam and
what will happen next from a point in
the specimen the emission beam would go
through the objective and
- this dichroic mirror and hit the
detector here you can see that it's the
emission light and also what another
thing could happen that other points in
the other focal plane could be
illuminated by that same excitation
light so other lights from other point
could also get into the detector if it
get into the detector it will produce
lot of blur that happens in the
fluorescence microscopy but in confocal
we have a particular pinhole which
reduces this out-of-focus lights only
allows the light to pass which is in
focus that means the point in the sample
is confocal that means the same foki
with the pinhole the pinhole is confocal
with this point the pinhole is confocal
with this point that is why the name is
confocal after that it would hit the
detector and detector would hit the
detector root sends the light and what
happens after so in our so back to our a
fluorescence Oblonsky diagram so when
after emission after excitation from s0
to s1 state it will get back to its
ground state at that time it would emit
an energy which is which correspond to a
particular wavelength and here
for say for instance our sample is
staying with GFP and for GFP our
excitation wavelength is 488 nanometer
and our emission wavelength is kind-of
5:09 emission peak is 5:09 nanometer
that means in green and it's in blue so
the heart of the confocal is this
pinhole so how this pin hole diameter is
regulated we will see in a moment
another important aspect of confocal
microscopy is called optical sectioning
optical sectioning optical sectioning so
here we have confocal objective lens you
have a confocal objective lens shape for
instance and this is the z-axis and here
we have a spherical specimen so at this
instance safer and safer at this
instance the lens is taking light from
this focal plane and detector is
detecting so if the lens is moving
around the z axis then it has moved
around the z axis and come here so now
it can it is able to image even the
deeper focal points it is able to image
from the tip of focal point of the
sample now what happened after that it
will image a particular from one plane
and after that it will reconstruct the
whole image it will reconstruct the
whole image plane by plane and pixel by
pixel it will build up the whole image
plane by plane and pixel by pixel so
this is the property of optical
sectioning so actually the image is not
a single image image is a composite
image of at least some 4243 sections and
all so say for instance how confocal
creates the image say for here we have a
smiley face over here so confocal would
do what confocal the laser of confocal
would scan this image point by point so
it is scanning the image point by point
it's not taking the whole picture at a
time rather it's scanning point by point
and then it will reconstruct the whole
image so it's all about point scanning
and reconstruction so it's point
scanning
and reconstruction now we will look
about the detector of the confocal so
you know in the detector section of the
confocal microscope we have something
called diode we have something called
diode arrangement it's nothing but a
photo cathode so say for instance this
light will go and hit the detector the
detector photo cathode this is the photo
cathode and we have a series of
arrangement of this kind of cathode such
that when light hits here photoelectric
effect will occur and each time the
effects get multiplied that is why the
name is photomultiplier tube as I have
told that confocal is a point scanning
method so in confocal we are scanning
point by point and gathering information
from each points so the light coming
from one point could be very small and
very little amount of light could be
available and to amp without amplifying
that particular light coming from that
point we are not able to get the signal
so for gaining the signal
this technology is photomultiplier tube
it's also called PMT it's a
photomultiplier tube as the name
suggests it's multiplying the the it's
multiplying the light coming from the
specimen and it's showing us a amplified
light another thing is the pinhole
pinhole diameter of the confocal is very
important the pinhole diameter of the
confocal is very important and how to
set the pin hole diameter if the pinhole
is too big then what happened this our
focus lights can get inside and produce
a blur the image quality would be
terrible and it would be like
fluorescence microscope but we don't
want
if the pinhole is too narrow then we
will loss a lot of information needful
information will be lost
so pinhole diameter should be regulated
and how it is regulated so if we draw
our intensity profile coming from any
particular point of the specimen so we
will see we have this kind of intensity
distribution and here I am drawing a
hairy disc Here I am drawing a airy disc
pattern corresponding to that particular
intensity profile so our pin hole
diameter have to be set in such that
this portion of the intensity we can
capture if our pinhole diameter is very
narrow we will miss a huge portion of
our intensity and if our pinhole
diameter is big then definitely we can
gain more intensity but side by side we
will gain outer focus light from other
focal point that is why our pinhole
diameter should be ideally 1 airy unit 1
airy unit so the pin hole diameter from
Riley criterion it's calculated like 1.2
to lambda by numerical aperture here
numerical aperture would be numerical
aperture of lens and that is why the pin
hole diameter have to be regulated or
otherwise we won't get a sharp and crisp
image and so as for summary we can say
the confocal microscope works just like
a fluorescent microscope apart from the
fluorescent microscope don't have a pin
hole but confocal has a pin hole and a
fancy way how can focus can actually
reduce the out-of-focus light and it
also has the ability of the optical
sectioning and by which it can take
image plane by plane and reconstruct all
the plane and it will give us a maximum
intensity map it will give us a maximum
intensity projection that could that
would have information from all
the plains hope you liked it please
subscribe hope you enjoy thanks